I was asked I was called and asked to
present Todd Phillips with an award at
the Montreal film festival I mean
comment accessible for best comedy
directed and they called me and it was
very formal and they were very excited
said Todd Phillips has recommended you
this is after the hangover recommended
you and we will provide you with the
first class ticket you'll be staying at
the best hotel in Montreal and it'd be
it'd be really amazing to I would be
very honored if you would do this for
him he'd be so excited and I was like
Todd would of course I'll do that first
class ticket to freaking the Montreal
films comedy fest I get to just stand up
and I'll present him an award have a
blast ah I'm there you know I I see Todd
were flying first class I'm like dude
you know it's grating and he looks at me
and he goes are you doing this I go he
goes I go I'm presenting with the award
because he doesn't meet us hey what are
you doing I go what am i doing I'm
presenting you with an award he goes you
are uh-huh and I go yeah of course I am
I'm that's why I'm flying here to give
you the award I got a speech and
everything you guys up Jesus Christ it's
so crazy or whatever he was tying his
shoe and he system comes and goes hey um
you know you got this award they want
you to somebody to present it to you who
do you think and Todd apparent was
trying to because I don't know if
Callens out doing stand-up out there
maybe he could do it uh whatever and it
just goes on to do something else so
that's all you had to say and it was
like wow the Todd bows would be honored
to be amazing and people fill in the
[ __ ] words for you man well I just
thought you really give us those I
thought ahead i do with them so you know
what i was going to say this well I i
I'm sorry I let me let me bring it full
circle which is that in Hollywood if one
if a star or somebody with power says
one tiny thing it'll set off a chain
reaction like so when Tom Cruise is
about to do a movie I know this Tom
Cruise will say yes to a movie the year
before he's thinking about doing the
movie there is a whole machine getting
ready in a place in case he says yes and
then when he says he's not going to do
it which is like just in mind you
everything goes it just crumbles down
it one person can have can have a ripple
effect that's [ __ ] beyond any but
you're also open my enough to start a
podcast because you can see the trend
and you're not like no serious radio or
bus man we're going with this and I
wasn't allowed to I wanted to have one
years ago but it was in my contract that
I wasn't allowed to there and then they
were like these little dudes that had
shows on sirius that had a podcast they
were doing out of the studio and I'm
like have a [ __ ] you doing one who's
like I just do it they don't care that
I'm like oh also my show so big that I'm
not allowed to do one and because your
show sucks you can do one fair enough
[ __ ] that like I started doing it well
no I had a guide to get a goddamn
[ __ ] contracted like entitled me to
have one yeah I can see why they would
like to know do we were what you're like
our thing it but they suck me from a TV
show one point I had a TV show to you
deal for MTV to just about my radio show
on TV and they will attract went to sign
it and the CEO of serious shut it down
why does that help serious people could
listen to your show TV no longer
subscribe the argument not an it in the
end because I did what you're doing
right now in the end it was like look we
have a personal problem with Viacom it's
not your fault don't worry we'll
compensate you fair enough they didn't
okay and then I did and then I did the
craziest rage on radio that I've ever
done to this day went nuclear I went you
ridicula at the CEO of Sirius XM and
eating i named him he did you fight
mm-hmm i got i got taken care of you
[ __ ] right I didn't mean to des alive
never I'd like you were that I never
know I don't play anything like these
days I kind of learned because I've
learned from my mistakes but this is
most of the journey has been a
accidental genius I didn't I didn't like
I envision this is going to happen no
but I'm doing what your heart tells you
do and I feel like passion and like
emotion like same thing when we left Fox
when I walked out of the office as I'm
walking out Brian was there the guy who
were dealing with goes hey man I know
you like to tell everyone
you know your fan base what's going on
we appreciate if you don't say anything
I went can't do that no problem says
maybe I walk out and went straight to
the studio next morning and what this is
what's going on next morning I find out
they lock the doors when we live in the
studio I like that's fine I'm give a
[ __ ] like that it's good to play that
man yeah I mean you're the same as me we
come from something where we paid we
worked hard to get where we are and I
ain't anybody's [ __ ] yeah and if you
try to push me I push you back because I
believe in I believe that I've already
been successful at things before and you
can take as much away from me as you
want I'll figure out another way to
direct to beat it now you can call that
blind you know stupid but whatever you
go into the world I want watch me yeah I
always said i would say i'll bet on
myself well brides up from that same cut
of cloth and he's like dude what the
[ __ ] are you doing this I'm like trust
me seems like he know what he's doing
with everything he does for sure it's
just it's different Brian doesn't want
to ruffle any feathers she wants
everyone to hawk some white dude that
ret Radner that isn't it oh no another
guy who sold reddit yeah she loved my
normal out I do tonight he did my
podcast back normal light out some
judges white dude yeah [ __ ] it I'll give
it a go not funny would it be if the
comments on it were just terrible well
the reddit comments about him on your
highness all like he's like you I think
I looks like me a regular you're saying
remaining Armenian guys are saying like
why shouldn't I be with Charlotte I mean
he's right you had a chance he'd spread
it with you today yeah and he's so rich
you could pay to have you as a peasant
like he's just yeah hey do you have you
as a life body double hahaha like wait a
minute is he gonna have you commit a
murder for a bummer and then this is so
[ __ ] up but I want her I almost want
her to be I want her to marry like
another super Alec the rockers upload
data make it like this so well rowdy got
engaged router Rousey's engaged to I was
brown Travis Browne who I hope he
doesn't hit her but like two of them
like they're gonna think about their
kids are going to be sick athlete yeah
and they're probably not going to want
to do it because your kids never look at
you to what you're doing
you know like their kids are gonna be
warriors your YouTube uh my dad's a
computer programmer okay yep example
though my brothers in computer
programming right all right we fulfill
okay I wake up well what about you know
anybody watching that Barry is there's
jay shaw big pop I mean the thing about
Brian count is both of his parents were
into comedy so naturally he's not they
were very funny they were funny and so
he knows that going opposite right there
I like my chance at the [ __ ] there
any comics that followed their parents
footsteps sure yeah any yes Andy Dick's
son Andy Dick son is comedy yeah you
news daughter does comedy i'm talking
like killed it i know there's like oh
well Don creases daughter John Cleese
daughter Holly shores dad was a Romanian
and mom on the comma Laraine Newman s
daughter does common in New York and
she's really good to create his daughter
sing Chris Elliott's daughter was on SNL
hello I mean you know let's Elliott and
she's a great sin chew on my mama should
you don't you don't get on SNL unless
you are you under unless you earned
unless you heard it